hey there gang it's your old pals uncle
Hank and Kippy we got some big news
folks are you garbage is coming to the
gas digital network that is correct me
and old Kippy are joining the gas
digital family baby and we could not be
more excited yeah guys this is [ __ ]
awesome and but don't worry not much is
changing if you listen to the podcast
it's still available free wherever you
listen the most 15 the most recent 15
episodes are available free on iTunes on
YouTube wherever you listen to podcasts
but the catalog of our you garbage will
be available on gas digital network.com
but don't you worry your little garbage
hearts
ladies and gentlemen because if you go
to gas digital network.com and use promo
code a yg you know I got you big man
talk to me I get you a 14-day free trial
and you'll save a dollar 50 a month come
along as you're signed up it's gonna be
uh whoo you'd be crazy not to sign up
for that that savings right there and in
this economy we can all use to save a
couple of bucks so spend it wisely folks
not only do you get the catalog of a yg
you also get the past catalog of Legion
of skanks of real last podcast I believe
you me with Michael Bisping Irish
goodbye Irish goodbye you get all the
shows on the network it's gonna be
[ __ ] worth it guys sign up use promo
code or a yg don't be a piece of trash
and gang don't forget to check out the
live stream every Tuesdays and Fridays
at gas digital network.com if you want
to watch it in HD high quality sign up
for the network you will not regret it
those live streams will be out three
days of where everybody else gets to see
them so you're the first one to smell
the garbage baby sign up today welcome
to another exciting edition of are you
garbage the show where you find out if
your favorite comedians are classy
individuals
absolute trash now here are your hosts
Kevin Ryan and H Foley hey everybody out
there and welcome back to everybody's
favorite new podcast this is our you
garbage the show will we sit down with
your favorite comedians and fun if they
grew up classy or if their complete
trash
I'm your host a trolli coming at you on
yet another beautiful day here in
Bluebell Pennsylvania my co-host back in
the New York groove up there in the
uptown uptown Washington Heights
cleaning up the fireworks he's under
siege Lee gentlemen he's under siege
with these illegal firecrackers give a
big round of applause for my good pal
mr. Kevin James Ryan everybody hey gang
happy to be here thanks for tuning in
shout out to Foley glad you put on your
makeup for us today I don't know what it
is dude it looks like you got some Rouge
on a little bit of lip liner that's what
I like to hear everybody guys thank you
so much for listening please make sure
you rate review subscribe on iTunes
where we are currently in the top 120
baby yes oh and we're cooking with gas
over here and also the full video is
available on YouTube make sure you
subscribe there as well and gang we
could not be more excited to have our
very special guests with us here today
he has a book out right now called the
liberal redneck manifesto he's a part of
the wall read tour in the wall read
podcast and he has his very own comedy
special coming out very soon entitled
greatest hits but the big question
everybody's mine today is he garbage and
since we started this podcast I seen him
drinking out of two different bottles so
I'm pretty sure he's [ __ ] trash give
it up for drew Morgan everybody yeah
what's up fellas it's great it's great
to be here for the audio listener he is
currently not wearing a shirt which is
[ __ ] pan out of ten great I can see
that house speeding down the highway
I'll tell you that right now I don't
know what your double-wide you're in I'm
in LA so I've sold out one but on that
note it's not quite noon here which I
think makes the shirt more acceptable
and less trashy but the beer
way more trash it's like it's not noon I
don't need a shirt anyway I'm drinking
this what do you what do you sleep in
that said that's that that's a good
that's a good little bar an issue right
there what do you normally sleep me well
we don't have kids me and my wife we
sleep in the nude the new really yeah
that's like swingers yeah you know us
we're just out here living that crazy
life stuff fart and bear has to ass Wow
nude sleeper both yeah all the time
uh I mean at least once a month she
wears panties Foley Jesus crazy you know
we're not [ __ ] animals you guys are
like porn stars whole time in LA it's
changed you and when I knew you you are
not a naked sleeper back when we New
York when you get naked to go to sleep
alright there's some intention there I I
fall asleep in whatever I had on you
know they mean but if you and if you get
undressed and then put on pajamas and go
to sleep that's intention but like
purposely taking everything off to get
the bed
alright you probably a thick piece on
yeah okay that you wouldn't you wouldn't
catch me [ __ ] creeper in the
apartment no no undies on I shower yeah
but you gotta understand everyone thinks
like it was just like stupid joke your
buddies tell you get married they're
like you know no more blow jobs or
whatever the [ __ ] that is they tell you
but it's like no no the beautiful thing
is you get to give up I don't give a
[ __ ] what she thinks to my dick it's no
it's not imagine every night I pull
these shorts down that reminder this is
what you you that you it's an oath is
over there's no vow you vowed to me with
this hey I do - the little guy again oh
no I just I just like being naked do you
know a name like not like in public
necessarily a depends but I just sleep I
like I don't even want many blankets you
know I'm saying out so I don't curl it's
like I don't want anything on me this is
my time don't cuddle sleep and make it
this guy's [ __ ] the brawny man please
try a cup of decaf no she said naked I
haven't heard nekkid
and there's nothing wrong with he huh so
joy was wondering though when we first
started that you all know you were on
the list for you were like the top three
people we wanted to have on don't
believe you I swore to I will side rows
I will still show you the list one
because you're your I think your argue I
think you're the first real southerner
we're having on so like cool the quiz is
definitely the south plays by its own
[ __ ] rules in a lot of a lot of ways
when it comes to garbage and culture I
think well yeah first of all it's trash
where we're from you know garbage that's
what you take out trash that's who I let
come inside me you know he's got no
shirt on he's got the wicker and and and
all I can describe is country store
furniture behind them and there's an
electric you didn't get that [ __ ] at
West Elm I'll pay that [ __ ] Bubba's
apple cider and furniture store if we
wake her up and we will and she'll be
super super happy about that let me tell
you my wife will come in here at some
point all this is her aesthetically and
I'm laughing so hard because you know
that story anthropology yeah
well imagine if that's run on down yeah
well imagine if it got a mess for a
little while that's my wife's aesthetic
like they're not on that anymore you
know what I mean but I had a rough
couple of years 23 to 24 yeah Wow that's
funny it looks good of course it does it
looks good nice little la [ __ ] spot
up there killing it I love it take me
back to talk I don't know I know you're
from the south what are you from
Kentucky Arkansas Michigan from Eastern
Michigan Upper Peninsula it's south of
Canada Foley no I'm from I'm from
Alabama and I'm kidding I'm from
Tennessee and a-something East Tennessee
a town called Sun bright that's
literally yeah we named it after the sun
i don't wow I guess our first mayor was
a caveman I don't Sun bright
infrastructure bad I holy [ __ ] alright
so went is Tennessee have like do are
you guys look down on cuz there's
dynamic of the South the other states
comparative Iraqi for sure yeah compared
to who anybody
well Alabama Alabama's the worst agree
11 what do you mean why is that because
it's the location of every [ __ ]
documentary about shittiness ever made
you watch the news I got a couple of
good running backs I'll tell you that
looks like if you if you're watching a
documentary about you know the civil
rights movement yes the setting and then
lately with all their [ __ ] it's
gonna be the setting of a lot of gay
rights documentaries dude they just true
they're trying to stay on top of the the
tourism industry of and this is where
the important guy got hit with a stick
they're hedging and they're hedging
their bets for the next like 50 years
something like people can go back and
say yeah yeah yeah all those pictures of
like you know dogs and and like [ __ ]
water hoses the guy holding it he's
still alive in Alabama he's not gone
that's [ __ ] up so he's or so so
Alabama's the worst so where does
Tennessee who's the best Georgia
Tennessee's I think the best and it's
not just bias it could be Georgia
because of Atlanta you know they get a
lot of uh I don't know modern whatever
because of Nashville though we do - of
course the problem with Nashville is
that it's like did you guys really fix
how backwards you are did you just find
a way to monetize it neither way I might
[ __ ] you guys as long as [ __ ]
[ __ ] from Connecticut keep buying
these country albums that some rich
prick made with a $75,000 truck I don't
give a [ __ ]
keep sending money our way but sure yeah
you guys polished it up a little bit in
a little bit of scratch you know what I
mean now it's your time to shine I like
that make sure that it's a the salads
good and you got nothing to worry about
you know what I mean but I do think it's
Alabama I don't think that's fair for
the record I mean Birmingham is one of
my favorite cities it's unbelievable
it's it's awesome its diverse it's like
all the things like a liberal person
would care about but it's also like it's
[ __ ] rad and cool so I do think
Alabama gets an unfair shake but Alabama
is the one we all [ __ ] on and we don't
[ __ ] on Mississippi cuz everything you
say about Alabama is true of Mississippi
Mississippi [ __ ]
they're so poor their 50th and
everything
yeah they are there are they are was at
the end of the roller coaster
Amazon's not going there I'll tell you
that
alright so Sun bright Tennessee growing
up brothers sisters I got one brother
uh-huh he's in prison for murder so if
you want to give me your quiz go ahead
but I feel sure yeah he murdered a
pedophile it had to do with a pill
addiction it's the whole thing we can
get into if you want to but it's like
it's nuts it's like if like John Grisham
wrote a novel about Juggalos like it's
[ __ ] up holy [ __ ] yeah so one brother
anyway we can move on if you want I mean
when you talk about it - I don't care
it's just that it's such a dark story if
you've never heard it before
even if I make what I think are great
jokes in my experience no one thinks for
fun for some people
yeah well dude that is [ __ ] a
hardcore that's a [ __ ] are you
garbage first right there yeah it's
manslaughter technically so just in case
books make sure there's an Asterix one
of his kids one of his kids will still
be under 18 when he gets up huh I'm
sorry he didn't do this when he was a
kid did he know he was dirty all right
so you guys grew up together so what was
it like growing up there oh you know I
mean that's one of those questions like
I didn't grow up anywhere else but it
was strange my brothers four years older
than me and we're very different you
know like I prefer kidnapping personally
but you know like my dad was a drunk
when we were younger
okay and he liked but he ended up as a
preacher and my brother got more of the
drunk and I got more of the preacher you
know what I mean that's my next move
I'll tell you that that's a good move
it's a good move next I gather yeah they
still are yeah yeah I mean they you know
there was a couple separations there I
remember we ended up in one place when
they were separated with like gray
paneling and I just remember I made my
mom cry because I was
the panelling so cuz I gotta I was mad
they were getting a divorce I know in my
eighth year of mine I was like and this
pen is [ __ ] ugly get your [ __ ]
together what kind of house is growing
was like a single-family house or was it
but we lived on Pleasant Ridge
Missionary Baptist Church Road shut up
that was not the name of the road it's
100% the name of the road it won't fit
on the sign I'll tell you that your
brother's screwed it on the letters of
charge you per letter now so he can't
get one out of years all that jokes for
like two people who knows my in prison
they charge you for everything but
anyway my papaw built like three of the
houses maybe four on that road I'm sorry
the what excuse me that's like a
grandfather but racist
haha yeah and now I feel like I tell
that it sounds like he's this like manly
man who's awesome he was a huge piece of
[ __ ] most of houses sucked he ripped
everybody off he's out of the family
[Laughter]
okay I was a god damn it you motherf er
I do y'all set me up
let's go let's get in the meeting Nelson
Mandela okay let's get to that later but
anyway my whole family lived on that
road and so that was an interesting
thing about growing up there it's a very
rural situation I graduated high school
with 43 people yeah yeah we started out
with 60 we lost quite a few to pregnancy
drugs and had to go to work but growing
up with like all your aunts you know
aunts around you like that because you
know it's like kind of a stereo Tenny
big family has craziness in it so you've
got I got one aunt who's been married
five times I got the aunt who is a
lesbian but we didn't have that word in
the 90s not where I grew up you know and
I mean so she just had a special friend
you had two aunt who was super religious
like I had all that within a stone's
throw and I had a bunch of cousins
running around because we're you know
we're Christian we don't believe in not
doing that so I grew up around all these
different types of folks but they were
my family
so that really I think is like how I
grew up quote-unquote more than
Tennessee I mean don't get me wrong
there was a lot of Tennessee involved in
all that obviously I kissed a couple of
cousins but it was only one I was just
trying to make a joke for the people
that they're listening I just picture I
picture you and your cousins growing up
like [ __ ] wild where you guys just
like running around [ __ ] my cousin
Tasha she's like she's in Birmingham the
city I'm sorry but she's married to a
doctor she's like high up at a Teach for
America she is one of the most care and
white ladies drinks wine every night you
know established people but when I get
her drunk and I get her around me we go
to the green room or something after a
show when I'm down there she starts
talking about she's got a scar on her
titty where I accidentally stabbed her
with a butter knife when we were 7 years
old you know she starts some of us
running around barefoot she start some
of me falling off the swing set trying
to wrap my big wheel down it and I'm
like damn we grew up feral you know like
we did that's some wild [ __ ] dude having
titties this guy stabbed and Eddie's I
threw the butter knife down in the
ground and it bounced all right what my
father was framed oh so your brother
said all right listen keep it moving
that's terrible I grew up rural but
surrounded by family if that makes there
was no one else like outside of that
road the next neighbor was half a mile
or a mile away
holy [ __ ] that's a big that's a big
trash thing I guess in the south it's a
little different but like the touching
property lines the touch that you share
with other family members there's always
a dead giveaway to
like you know even if they everybody
just stay over here we'll pull our
resources and like once it has to watch
all the kids right yeah what did you
order your dad do growing up he worked
for the railroad he was a union man now
did your grandfather your grandfather
owned all this property slaves now he
didn't he was too young
nah but he owned all that property uh
yeah my or my dad did once upon a time
like my dad bought some property from
him and then bought more but yeah it was
all in the family Wow [ __ ] old why are
you drinking two things you told me it
was early in the morning in LA are you
drinking a beer yeah that's what I was
saying I was saying it's early so that
explains why I don't have a shirt on but
it's early so I guess that's not a good
excuse for why I'm drinking yeah you're
drinkin it's a it's a German beer story
yeah I I'm hungover so I'm drinking a
beer and to be completely honest sorry
this is a very trash
I hadn't drink in like three weeks and
that's why I'm so hungover from
yesterday yeah you got to keep that
tight little body on you I get it big
man over here yeah we'll say it's that
not the sadness anyway all right so you
got it so you get out of high school
obviously you did good in high school
yeah I was valedictorian actually having
both people but I mean it's 40 43 yes so
that was my junk back then I'm smart
enough to realize I am the top 10% this
is actually isn't working for me did you
go to school about two hours Boston
College that's like the devil's advocate
I would say zero to 2021
touch and go when you went when you went
to Boston College had you been up north
been and the cities or anything like
that before not to live but I mean you
know and we know how planes work where
I'm from but no I'd never live I had
lived in Australia and I had lived in
South Africa as part of a study abroad
program I should tell everyone listening
and judging the [ __ ] out of my family
deservedly so
my mother's an educator she's a
brilliant [ __ ] woman she's a
storyteller she like pushed me to study
abroad and all that my dad when he did
finally quit drinking I mean he is a
preacher not just like I hate gays I
mean he's like [ __ ] smart he knows
the Bible in and out
we're just hillbillies you know I'm a
queer just [ __ ] dumb Barbie in you
it's just so you have that you have that
edge to you yeah well trade a guy tour
with Trey Crowder he's you know way more
famous to me he's got this thing where
he's like it's it's like he gets drunk
sometimes it's very funny and also sad
he gets drunk he's like oh it'll go away
I'll ruin it will ruin it it's just in
us boys this [ __ ] Ennis man yeah I'm
gonna do something [ __ ] up I know we're
literally going through that right now
your brother's like what's wrong it's
quarantine killing comedy yeah but also
some things I tweeted man that's [ __ ]
that's that's like that is like it just
that's that's like generational trash
words just in you and like once you
start it's you can never fully get away
from it well and I've talked to a lot of
comedians about that and a lot of us
have because a lot of us come from
various versions of [ __ ] up
backgrounds sure of course and I can't
of course speak on behalf of any
minority group or whatever but that one
thing is sometimes a difference and I
and I realized at one point where like a
lot of em in my experience black folk
don't have that as strong but it's
because like they never feel like
they're fully in the club where as trash
people are like I'm in the door if I can
just make it into that main room before
anyone realizes my invitation is
[ __ ] yes I
we because we're white or whatever sec
we almost have the security that we've
made it and it's like some part of ya
know they're gonna smell my cheap coal
once I get in there right right whereas
you know the brood on right whereas
again just in my experience from talking
to a lot of black folks they're like no
they're never let me in period where as
a part of me is like no I think I've got
a law degree I think I can go in there
and then like it's like in the in the TV
show you cut to me three seconds later
yeah they found out they saw my teeth
and they knew it again they saw me
drinking tang and they threw me right
out I don't know right where is your
black friend and everyone it was like a
[ __ ] told you let's go let's get the
[ __ ] out of here those [ __ ] alright
let's give them some more you garbage
here man this is this is an interesting
one talk about [ __ ] zero to sixty
yeah from Sun great Tennessee to [ __ ]
Boston College my niece just got into
Boston College oh man Congrats it's
gonna be a golden eagle I'm hoping she
goes all the way senator Congress
something I need some [ __ ] kickback
money and a couple of [ __ ] no big
contracts to keep this operation afloat
is she an undergrad you mean yeah that
was that was a culture shock for me the
law school wasn't on the regular campus
but we had to go there for various
things and going - a giant being on a
giant Northeast's old college campus
like that where like it was just such a
culture shock for me man they have
imagined to form the uggs with the vest
you know and ski and all this other
stuff that I thought only rich people
were allowed to do don't do coke all
right there we go
say I found my people and by that I mean
the dealers wait have you ever been
skiing now yeah yeah yeah a couple times
nice did you ski in your jeans no but if
you want a trash story I just goddammit
I can't believe I'm telling this my wife
is probably over all me we went skiing
with the law school group we had just
started living together right when I was
finished in law school and she called a
girl in my classic [ __ ] mm-hmm
and this I've met your I've met your
wife a handful of times and she's she's
a bit of a fire in full
yeah handfuls the right word anyway it
was over a beer pong game and I was like
that's classic trash classic trash dude
I gotta get I can't go ski and what was
I came up a beer pong that is awesome
all right let's get into some questions
here let's quit screwing around now I
understand the rule background I get it
let's see if we can piece this together
a little bit here first thing we like to
ask everybody is what was the name of
the grocery store mmm that your mother
went to while you were growing up okay
when I was younger it was called
Darnell's food market one guy yeah hold
on that was in Wartburg a town away all
right then
they gotta save a lot and she started
going there then we got a small chain
quote-unquote chain the dude on three of
them his name was RB and my aunt Donna
my aunt Barbara worked there and she
started an affair with the potato chip
man whose name was punkin and then he
kept on her he's gonna leave his wife
for her he never did she hated him she
almost got in trouble for stalking him
she finally separated in her life from
him that was over at my wedding I found
out that pumpkin is my wife's first
cousin and my aunt had to see the guys
issues in love with with his family that
he wouldn't leave for her who was the
potato chip man at the grocery store in
my town that was no longer there because
the guy who owned it burned it down for
insurance money
give me my [ __ ] prizes Christ
so who catered the wedding Darnell we
got a pig from a farm and cooked it
ourselves I swear to God
dude that's great uh I want to stay in
the wedding where was your big wedding
say so much about families where was the
wedding we got married in the church I
grew up in its Presbyterian on my album
the well-read live tour album my closing
joke is about being
they're stoned for the like Christmas
play and thinking these people were too
[ __ ] fancy because they had a
beautiful church with like I was like
stained glass
I got stained clothes this is [ __ ] up
but then we did the reception in her
parents yard but she had a lawyer
Popoff he was get passed on but my point
is they had like a really nice farmhouse
okay nice that's classy that's classy
was there what was the dress code at
said there olive here jerseys yeah that
wasn't included in the invitation I will
say on behalf of my people they know
better I mean there were probably people
in like they're good jeans
yeah nice okay we were talking about
forget who we were talking to maybe I
forget who it was but they were saying
that their their cousin still wears
football jerseys to weddings cuz it's a
nice cuz that's it was going out peace
it was Gillison gig wanna kill us his
cousin's cousin Frankie or something
like that was the wedding can I ask you
this was the wedding was it all you
contribute was at a cash bar it was all
you can drink and my brother-in-law I
brought moonshine that's good we had
beer we provided beer but he brought
moonshine just on his own see it look at
that and that shows you right there and
that's kind of the point behind the
whole podcast is is it doesn't matter
whether you're rich or poor you can
still do trashy things now you know you
came from humble beginnings you're
hard-working people you get married and
you still take on the responsibility to
make sure everybody has a good time with
food and drink you'll go to [ __ ] rich
people's weddings and it'll be a cash
bar paying for your own drinks like a
[ __ ] jerk-off it's unbelievable yeah
I don't that you know classy we need a
different word for it because that's so
associated with money yeah but I used to
work a you know we'll probably when I
met you guys I worked at a catering
venue in New York part time my wife was
a manager there and I would work on the
weekends and they had a lot of money it
was like in the middle of [ __ ] you
know Times Square and so it was rich
people that work and sometimes they had
no class
yeah no couth as I think
the old-timers will call it no couth
yeah their people are coolest my people
are toothless I think we're all right
Kippy what do you got all right let's
see any of your houses growing up or you
know college in your 20s or even
currently have any your house has ever
had carpet in the bathroom yeah yeah
there was a time I think it was uh I
think it was always meant to be
temporary but end up last in a couple of
years they pulled something up in our
bathroom because of a problem and just
put down the cheapest thing they could
buy and then like three or four years
later my mom finally replaced it and it
was like that really thin out quick
follow-up question what was the problem
in the bathroom floors got ruined
because I I recently had to call my mom
out about the carpet in the bathroom the
carpet in the bathroom comes in the fact
that we had new carpet put into our
bathroom okay and my mom is now denying
and saying no that was the carpet that
they had and then we tore it up but I
specifically remember the night that
they did tore tear it up it was like a
week after my mom bought this brand-new
carpet
my dad came home hammered from from a
softball game and took a shower without
closing the curtain and water got all
over the bathroom and ruined the carpet
we tried to salvage it by hanging it
over the pool which was my god dude
that's that's great you are some gore
Biagio though that's what I come from
and I was just curious if you had a
similar situation I was somebody
somebody a mentorship right I was too
young to remember what happened but my
dad was drinking when I was too young to
remember stuff we'll go ahead and say
our drunk dad I'm sure I was connected
at some point yeah fair enough bad
though when you pee on the floor you
don't have to wipe it up you know you
just you can just stick in or buddy yeah
oh you're not gonna get out the [ __ ]
you have to jump back that thing you
know yeah using the shopvac in Reverse
as a blower that's real copper
did you want to know how right my dad is
so blue-collar so trashy he uses that to
vacuum the house dude so like there he
would just be like he'd be [ __ ] doing
the master bedroom with like meanwhile
he just like he wiped the nozzle that's
right I'm the cleaner by the way I don't
want you think that we skipped over it
wasn't heard I did hear you saying that
the name of your mother's grocery store
was a man named Darnell
I just I didn't I wanted to go back and
make sure you knew that we that we heard
that I still remember the local radio
commercials and their tagline was
Darnell's your key to good eating and
they would all their coupons had keys on
them like that's the advertising that
seeps in that's so funny and for sure
you know Darnell recorded that radio
recorded that Adam self yeah and the
reason they used the key is like that
was the free clipart they could afford
you know I mean like they just what key
is free we'll build our whole campaign
around that it has nothing to do with
eating its the starfish to your dreams
listen my goodness all right I want to
ask you growing up in the environment
that you grew up
did you ever hunt or catch or kill
anything that you had for dinner
personally or in the family in the
family yeah my dad's a big-time hunter
and he got let go from the railroad cuz
he got caught selling weed and he
refused to roll over on his friends and
or admit it but because unions are Sam
and the [ __ ] backbone of this country
let's eat that in there in this podcast
Amen brother shoutout to the Screen
Actors Guild exactly yeah the writers
been paying my insurance but that just
ended I don't know what I'm gonna do
anyway is Cobra trash like if you get
cold I'm sure it's oh my god
I hate they sent me it was like this
[ __ ] paperwork was like 87 pages and
at the end it was like this is how much
you owe us and I was like throw this
away
if your insurance providers named after
a reptile they're like this is an
acronym I'm like no it's a venomous
snake that kills people random to your
future
my dad didn't lose his job he had to
like fight him but he was laid off with
no pay during that time and that whole
winter we ate deer meat and I secretly
think it was like the happiest times of
my life of his life excuse me of his
life I meant to say like he didn't have
to go to work like was protecting his
friends was sticking up for what he
believed in and was getting to like hunt
for his family yeah my dad's like a
rugged [ __ ] so he's like he's
like who Joe Rogan pretends to be so
like my dad is like like an you know I'm
saying like he was like I'm ready for
this so we did that a lot and I hunted
some and I've killed a couple things but
I was bad at it my brother was good at
it not rolling over on your friend
selling weed that's [ __ ] class right
there all right yeah that's a [ __ ]
point if I've ever seen one
this kids climbing out of the dirt I
like it I know the reason it's
manslaughter and not murder has a lot to
do with my family not rolling over on
their friends pretty good pretty good
holy [ __ ] okay anyone in your family
ever owned a pontoon boat immediate
family or can I count my uncle mark Oh
uncle marks whether you own pontoon
boats well buckle mark owns pontoon
boards what time I got one free tickets
to a race and my and then I carve God
and then my car race NASCAR north these
people you came NASCAR NASCAR the
Bristol whatever Motor Speedway it
wasn't Formula one I can tell you that
it was Bristol which is in East
Tennessee which is one of the most fun
tracks in the most popular [ __ ] sport
in North America [ __ ] I know anyway
mm kidding but uh anyway I gave those
Dunkel mark
to fix my car uncle marks the best yeah
dude a pontoon boat is is is pure trash
dude the only reason it exists is to
drink not on land that is a little bit
it moves at like two knots an hour it
barely [ __ ] they barely move some we
have a bathroom oh no man you get me hi
it's good I'm fired up make that thing
at the international waters and get
another beer two boats and I'm really
thirsty all of a sudden of course and
I'll be right back yeah go ahead and get
another beer and gang just a quick
reminder just want to let everybody know
as everybody does know we're joining -
digital network joining the gas digital
family and we could not be more excited
we're gonna be doing our first episode
tomorrow that's Tuesday this episode
comes out on a Monday so do us a favor
gang once you sign up for gas digital
you can use promo code a yg you're gonna
save a dollar 50 on your subscription
and you're gonna get a 14 free 14-day
free trial so check it the [ __ ] out man
it's gonna be a good time and we get to
wet our beak a little bit you know what
I mean that's right Kippy was was your
uncle mark your real uncle yeah well
yeah you marry my aunt Lysa
they were married before I came into the
world and they're still married gotcha
pontoon boats man love a good dude if
you're out on a pontoon boat with a
cooler full of ice down beers
yeah good night yes I'm bud you're only
worried if you guys have everyone listen
if you guys remember teddy Tasha who
accidentally stabbed with a butter knife
that's her dad that's funny dude have
you ever had to call 9-1-1 on a family
member I would never do that yeah yeah
let me tell you something I've asked
that 10 times or five maybe five times
that's a great [ __ ] answer drew
Morgan that's a great [ __ ] answer
right there this guy plays it [ __ ]
by-the-book I like all right man ease
all right okay let's see anyone in your
family ever in a cover band oh I got
people who play in church a lot which I
they're only doing cover songs it's just
respectable though that's respect
that's for the Lord if you're singing in
church yeah if you're playing you know
the [ __ ] Bee Gees or something it my
cousin Sherry's my favorite boyfriend of
hers ever growing my cousin Shari was
like my babysitter his name was John he
was in a cover band he's rad as [ __ ]
he's still an old like redneck hippie
which I know if you're out there
listening like we mean a redneck yeah
very rare most of them died when the
Allman Brothers Band broke up but John
he's got like long hair smokes weed he
was in a cover pan nice man all right
what do you got big guy
are there any member of membrane members
of your family that went to hairdressing
school but did not finish for personal
reasons I might be a yes I feel like I'm
certain some of my aunt's did and I
don't remember the reason I'm laughing
so hard is that describes Trey's sister
literally to the guy I tour with anyways
not as far as I know but probably okay
all right that's pretty good I like
anybody in your family ever owned just a
hot tub not connected to a pool just a
hot tub got a couple of bucks together
maybe so that someone had good credit
they financed one for like thirty two
hundo
my old man's talking about getting one
right now I got my aunt Patti did back
in the day that I can remember and it
was at her trailer at the time she was
with my uncle bubby I have no idea what
his real name is and I won't say it
because he was a coke addict they were
involved in the highway 27 Club which
was a bar with no windows that the Hells
Angels used to run drugs see she ended
up you know growing up a little bit
where her days are behind her if you
know her hot tub days well she's passed
away rest in peace aunt patty but she
put her hot tub days behind her before
she passed there you go became a
paralegal she was the [ __ ]
ah that's not too bad what other names
what other nickname
of aunts and uncles do you have that
aren't their names cuz I got a couple of
those that's of real trashy to bubbies
probably the best one
my uncle Gerald I knew his uncle Jed I
didn't know his name was Gerald I know
that's a shortening but Jed is such a
you know that's a name till they got
divorced like I saw the divorce papers
or something I was like aunt Barb's
divorcing Gerald who the [ __ ] is
Gerald's faith why did you see their
divorce papers
why wouldn't I you know this later in
she's probably bitching about how I've
never seen a [ __ ] I've never seen a set
of documents I didn't get to review them
what I could do Morgan over his 25 lives
be fair my little [ __ ] self at 12 or
whatever I probably was like yeah kid
she's taking you for everything you
[ __ ] [ __ ] idiot what is this
[ __ ] about her getting custody of a
snake you deserve weekends at least you
don't have this realized about trash you
know what it is among families is like
if you just open with you're embarrassin
of course like Nestle trash like we just
we don't have enough pride in that kind
we sit under the rug really you know
what I mean yeah it's like there's no
rugs who can afford a rug a bathroom I
saw so I'll say this we as Irish
Catholics we do a little sweep we we do
a little emotional sweeping for sure do
a lot of emotional sweep yeah we do that
in the south and we had it under our
manners that's also their manners are an
inability or unwillingness to deal with
[ __ ] mm-hmm yeah that makes sense I
can see that absolutely that's funny you
got to toe the line with those yeah yeah
do you currently own or have you uh ever
owned a dvd/vcr combination player yeah
I have one in college it was a gift from
a family member
nice was it new Jen ain't gonna need
this no more
one thing I love about
people that I also just realized is
pretending or being like offended did
someone ask you something like that
maybe was it new like I can't afford a
combination DVD VCR but also that's a
valid question but yeah it might have
gotten some use [ __ ] at some point you
know his brother bought him something
for Christmas I think it was he bought
like a nerf gun for like five bucks off
the neighbor and then wrapped it in a
trash bag and gave it to him on
Christmas I was like I'm like I'm trash
but that is a [ __ ] whole nother level
dude you [ __ ] bought a five-dollar
nerf gun off your neighbor and then put
it in a trash bag I think that's what
that poor kid out of open on Christmas
morning that's one of those like [ __ ]
memoirs that's like super trash because
you can get your hands wrapping paper
ain't [ __ ] you know yeah a thousand
dollars a roll its man that's I'm sorry
is he okay now I still got the nerf gun
though it's the only gift his dad ever
gave him I would like to know this song
and gentleman such as yourself how do
you feel about the food item known as
imitation crab meat I love it love it
way more than I do crab meat that's a
garbage first rate air folks that's cuz
that's what they put in cheap sushi
right yes yeah yeah so see I went not
trashy with it we're talking my sushi
but I like well like I do like seafood I
genuinely do you know I just want to
remind everyone listening we've already
talked about it I did go to law school
but I just don't like I don't like crab
it's just I just don't like the flavor
but I love imitation crab are you a
crawdad guy do you got you do crawdads
down there I will a little bit we don't
do them where I'm from that's more of a
bayou that's like Florida Panhandle a
Louisiana type [ __ ] what would be what
would be like what would be a local
sunbright dish that's some bright dish
yeah I mean you can't eat pills we
snorted you set the mickey's that's
some Brett is so small I don't like East
Tennessee where any saucy we're in that
part of Appalachia and I think our main
dish is there we have our own type of
barbecue it's close its close to
Carolina barbecue and we do like gravy
biscuits matter of fact here's the trash
thing for today
my wife had some jeebies we a fan of
ours of my tour and my wife became
friends and she found out that that
girl's brother lives out here and makes
gravy biscuits on Sunday and sells them
to people he makes a huge pot of
everything and then sells them I woke up
at 8:45 on a Sunday to go get them we
ate those gravy biscuits this morning
and then my wife went back to sleep it's
funny you bring that up because somebody
on Twitter what a people listen to the
podcast asked us about something he
calls [ __ ] on a shingle yes so the way
the way his his mom did it was it was
peas
you know the cream sauce and tuna and I
was saying that yeah in in Pennsylvania
in Philly we do [ __ ] on a shingle it's
chipped beef the cream on toast and you
have it in breakfast so you're basically
talking about sausage gravy sorry is
gravy with biscuits instead of toast and
if we do it on toast we call it [ __ ] on
shingles there you go about that [ __ ]
that gravy is it doesn't matter you pour
it over anything buddy its Willie its
liquid bread and this is a gross thing
to say but it's true wet bread is the
best [ __ ] thing
Pizza gravy biscuits [ __ ] bread
pudding like wet bread sounds gross but
every version of wet bread we eat is the
[ __ ]
dude I love what I love what I'm eating
a hero and a little piece of the rolls
real he said wet bread what the [ __ ]
that was too funny I like wet bread
that's alright so there you go there you
go biscuits and gravy god damn that
shit's [ __ ] good yeah man there's a
place there's a place in New York that
does them Jake
pickles up on the other side they do is
good oh it's great it's all food I think
I'm in there and Jewish inspired it's
really good I think I've been there and
II had a friend from Virginia West
Virginia who took us there and I was
super she's just you know like what are
we doing here I even have a bit about
like going to some place in Brooklyn and
they've got like country theme on the
wall you know I've got a whole bit about
him like you know they gentrified my dad
out of his jeans with your [ __ ]
Carhartt jacket or yeah so I was like I
don't know and it was good and I think
that was a place yeah someone someone
some of them get it right up here for
sure now how do you feel about like a
Cracker Barrel I'm fine with Cracker
Barrel you know it's like it's like
Nashville country music to me it's like
that's not what country music is but I'm
so glad somebody took our [ __ ] and
they're convincing you idiots to spend
money on it kind of yeah I don't I'll
eat in Cracker Barrel what do you know
what is it like an Applebee's like a
southern apple go it's like it's like a
diner with a little bit more heart oh
it's a country it's a country each
country diner yes it's a country diner
but on the way out they have the gift
shop that's an all country mm-hmm they
have like suckers and like you know
things to the house and all this big
mouth you can get the big mouth Billy
bass there that's a nice word
that's emotion have you ever owned one
of those no lost in the divorce anyway
you know any that might be better than
snake I might need to put that in my act
I'm gonna be better than snake seriously
Foley in custody of a snake in custody
of a big good I'm seeing on the weekends
you know what Cracker Barrel has that's
awesome the old-school root beer barrels
I don't know how you guys feel about
those my favorite old-school be
goodnight my god it's some of the candy
with the wax you know well those things
are crazy good back in the day nose lunk
it was more wax than anything all right
I was sorry with it all right but we're
not talking that what are you talking
about that we're talking about root beer
barrels little hard candies that taste
like root beer and look like little tiny
barrels and they're wrapped in usually
red
or like orange and you know this might
be like one of those this ain't for us
like we didn't spend any time in the
gift shop even when I was little and I
think I don't must be like yeah this is
for people who think my life is a museum
[Laughter]
who I want you to know I really respect
your culture I visited the Cracker
Barrel angry now does your family make
them root beer barrels is that really
given all right so now obviously you got
a little bit you know you got a
successful career you got out you went
to law school what I'm saying you're not
you know you're not home on the [ __ ]
range anymore you're moving you can be a
drink coffee are you a coffee drinker
not really I drink it I'll drink iced
coffee sometimes okay where do you get
your ice coffee if you have a go-to spot
no I know I just get it I [ __ ] just
mix it up over here I mean I do instance
sometimes now my wife's a big coffee
snob but I just did this morning and
this is why I'm so I took some of her
she had made it okay so he makes instant
coffee and he's really turned to trash
this guy there it is where were you
going with this line of questioning I
wanted to see if there's more if he
falls more of a Starbucks guy or a more
of a Dunkin guy he'd be a Dunkin guy
from Boston I [ __ ] love Duncan and I
do think it's cuz the possum did before
I ever started doing comedy the first
bid I wrote was just just to my friends
was about being in a [ __ ] Duncan and
just how you can go to any duncan in
boston and every single time the same
scenario it's gonna play out it's just
one of those [ __ ] dude calling you
hey I'm a dunks know you want something
yeah latte what are you [ __ ] queer
I'm not getting you a latte I can't let
that [ __ ] order out of my mouth you
know like yeah I love that you could go
there in Boston and I guess it reminded
me of home you know you could you could
see a [ __ ] dude who was on his way to
a job that most people would never ever
do or want to do and he was saying some
questionable things but he seems like
he's just wearing his [ __ ] coffee
black and hate in the world and I guess
I guess what I'm saying is I miss my dad
guys well I asked because my family is
that they're all construction workers
that's all and there it's a Duncan it's
a bustling family it's a wah wah family
or a Duncan family all right yeah we're
Tiger marked and then you know we make
our own coffee but yeah sure so like I
recently my uncle who's like all these
like an old [ __ ] blue-collar like
pipe fitter that's what he does he
recently got into like he's somehow let
his guard down and got into Starbucks
coffee because like somebody had like
just somebody he deserves it that's
great he deserves it have you tried and
I'm I'm the same way it took me like
years to stop going to Duncan to finally
like confidently walk into a Starbucks
to be like let me get a venti Pyke black
let's do it you know yeah no I love that
that's ingrained and that's ingrained in
that generation of construction workers
that is ingrained in them my wife got my
dad fancy [ __ ] coffee for Christmas
and she was I'm gonna get your dad this
he loves coffee me and him we wake up
and drink it together you know where the
coffee freaks in the family when were
there on Christmas mm-hmm okay sure
and then when he opened it he was like
thanks and I was like yeah see I [ __ ]
told you but then like a week later like
he ran out of his folders so he made it
and he was like calling her and then
they just think they became these little
like coffee girl you know like tell it's
great dude and I was like he deserves it
he deserves good [ __ ] coffee of course
man that dude there's that generation of
guy that caught it that guy that's cut
from that cloth you know they don't know
know like let me get they go to Duncan
they get an extra large or like extra
sugar extra cream or what and just like
keep it moving I'm like put a little
[ __ ] soil in there you know all you
do for yourself do it right you know
it's branding just don't call it self
care you know what I mean just like
that's the problem those guys don't care
just don't call it any of that [ __ ]
just be like hey it's better drunks or
whatever exactly a it's stronger coffee
there you go
so you know sell it is that that's funny
all right I think only got one more left
how about you big man
true Mugen I would like to know two
things then and now what is the current
brand of toothpaste that you're using in
your household and what was the brand of
toothpaste droppin up at your beds you
have no idea how [ __ ] you guys are
cutting right to the heart of issues in
America right now grow it on down start
now I want to go whichever this is to in
there right now and I had literally two
days ago I was looking at it like who
the [ __ ] have I become you say doctor
brahmers are [ __ ] mrs. Myers it's
Tom's charcoal Tom's charcoal or coal or
whatever the [ __ ] it is charcoal and
with that for it I'll tell you that much
and then the other one is some kind of
all-natural whitening thing my wife
bought here's what's extra funny about
this the Tom's is Tom's with fluoride I
got that in protest
she got this whitening non fluoride
because she's all woman like we can't
have the fluoride and I'm laughing
because I'm like no this is stupid
look we've forgotten who we are I will
go to the store right now and get
toothpaste with fluoride and I came home
with Tom charcoal but it's got [ __ ]
fluoride in it
god damn baby write a country song about
that [ __ ] let me ask you this
alright put a pin in that for a second
if you went home for Christmas with your
wife would you take that toothpaste with
you and use it in eastern Tennessee I
would use it but she would bring it with
us and I don't know you know I don't
know where that is on the trash Navas my
wife packs toothpaste there you go there
now that's all right covering up a
little white lie like that same little
face with the boys when you're having a
Budweiser no she literally would bring
it like when I go on the road I just
forget it and then have to get whatever
the hotel gives me there you go okay so
now that we've gotten here what was the
brand of toothpaste growing up I think
it was called Colgate is that is that is
that a medium one that's right that's
great the middle okay main any main
street any town USA
and in crest but it's not bad yeah we
know we were not a crest family I feel
like I heard my mom say that before
yeah well freshest garbage now okay but
Aquafresh when you were a kid
that's all anybody wanted was to make
that little [ __ ] swirl with the
aquafresh with the three different
colors we might always look like bird
[ __ ] oh my god about to be like a little
bit back in my head I was like you
[ __ ] hack what do you talk [ __ ] kind
of hack would say that you know the
trashiest was closed up you ever have
closed up I don't remember if a cinnamon
toothpaste it's red it's a real shitty I
don't think there's a it's just sugar
I've never even heard of that dude
that's that's that's trash is below my
pay grade for sure I don't think that
Darnell carried that wasn't the key to
anything who the [ __ ] is Tom what that
reminds me of communism get it out of
here all right I got one more it's like
it's a very common one on the show so
you said you grew up in a single family
home did you have a garage in that house
no but my dad has a shop now that he
built over my basketball court growing
okay so growing up was there anywhere
did you have one fridge or two fridges
in the house was there one in the
basement or some the basement one in the
basement what was in that basement
fridge mr. Morgan when I was real young
it was my dad's beer mm-hmm anyway
freezing and there was a freezer beside
it full of meat now you had a separate
freezer as well as the yeah for the deer
for the deer and the turkey might they
have a kill I don't know what replaced
the beer in the fridge I think we mostly
use the basement freezer when you stop
drinking mm-hmm you know that ain't bad
that is pretty [ __ ] you I don't think
we've had that answer a full-size fridge
and the freezer I don't think we've ever
had
okay I think that's a rural thing
because again going back to Darnell's
Darnell's was a 25 minute drive you know
that like you know Hardaway was it
that's like you know the deep freezer
was it was trash but it was also like
look we're not we're only shopping once
a month
I don't think that's trash that's it's
functional that's the thing all right
I'm pretty classy if you got extra
freezer and extra fridge money laying
around a man unions
I'm telling you southern belle yeah
goddamn country I just got two more
questions I just want to know both kind
of in the same genre one have you ever
worn anything that was made of turquoise
the stone yes is that trashy cuz it's my
wife's favorite jewelry but no I haven't
I don't know if that's trash I don't
know if it depends I'm a be overly if
there's a lot of turquoise I feel like I
get a little bit of trash points cuz I
was like do you mean the stone or the
color my grandma's couch was of course
alright
that's setting that aside have you ever
had a belt that had your name on it
I have many have have had many but I'm
about to give you the answer that I know
no one can top on your podcast now and
for the future this is my challenge to
future trash people garbage excuse me
garbage paper I have a belt right now
that has my tour name on it well red
tour he says well read that my brother
made in prison Jesus Christ comes full
circle that is [ __ ] awesome I was
gonna say that's like new money trash
but then your brother your brother
making it in prison was a [ __ ]
curveball I didn't see coming
yeah yeah Wow Thank You P what's your
what's your verdict on this guy here
what are you thinking alright this is a
this one is a [ __ ] this is a tough
this is a tough call I gotta be honest
with you right hold on can I tell you
two stories that
is this a quick I don't know I know yes
I know you guys signed a contract
recently good Congrats I don't know we
got to do an hour on the nose all right
cool
yeah I'm drunk let's be here all day all
right first of all let me say for the
listeners here's what happened my
brother remember there was an addict
this is sad but I'm just gonna get
through it cuz I feel like everyone's
like what the [ __ ] and it scares parts
for that's trashy a guy that one of my
aunts aunt patty who's ended up getting
out of the game of seven coke two Hells
Angels and became a paralegal she was
married to the do my brother murdered
but years ago that's how small my town
is he it turns out later in life is a
pedophile and a predator in general my
brother's a bad bad addict and was
essentially second his new dick for
drugs and that guy that guy yeah and the
guy had become like a like a drug
counselor type dude so he was like
signing off he kept my brother employed
like he was doing a lot for my brother
and but he was blackmailing him and
eventually that ended in death for him
and the reason I said it was like a John
Grisham novel written by Juggalos is
that all happened a month before I
graduated law school that very guy back
when he was a partier and my dad was a
partier in our small town kept my dad
from killing a dude one night so it's
like all this weird anyway I'm not
trying to I just feel like a lot of
people were like what the [ __ ] where was
he killed a dude who was shitty to him
he deserved to go to prison but not
forever
and he didn't go forever and whatever it
sucks I promise the next two stories are
way funny
sure no I wanted to know I was this to
help your case what were we doing here
well one step that was i sat at the top
of your podcast that my brothers in
prison for murder and I wanted because I
loved him to people to know that like
I'm not saying we should throw him a
parade but I do feel like the kids in my
neighborhood should high-five him you
know what I mean like I got that vibe
from from from just how you said it that
he that he killed a pedophile okay all
right I'm sorry you can see on the
highway real
these two quick stories one will make a
case for me being trash and one are
gonna make the case I love it
closing reasoning arguments alright the
reason my hair is a [ __ ] lawyer
that's because everything's closed down
right now I shaved my head week three of
quarantine after taking my dog's pain
pills and going full Britney Spears
there's my dress pain pills well it's
not like he but he wasn't he didn't need
him anymore like they had a long I don't
remember
honestly it was a situation where we
were bored we were looking to her
medicine cabinet there's something to do
at quarantine and I was like the
difference between dog pain pills and
human pain pills and I looked it up
pretty much nothing about 40 bucks
that's what so I did them and then
shaved my head I want full Britney
Spears is from Louisiana so that's the
most white-trash thing I've done during
warranty is shave my head while on pills
I don't dog pills yeah and then here's
the other one
I got to meet Nelson Mandela when I was
studying abroad in South Africa his
grandson was in my dorm or whatever
which is very different like your dorm
is different that's a big deal it's
almost like being in a frat like if you
have to go to regular meetings together
and stuff so I got invited to the farm
I met Mandela it was crazy I heard him
speak in English in his native language
it was super humbling you know they did
a big thing in me in the paper back in
my college like all that stuff but
trader visits Nelson Mandela
drew Morgan is not more welcome here
anymore
well it's looking cool [ __ ] what state
are you from Foley Pennsylvania a known
bastion of non-racist anyway that's how
[ __ ] the whole system no get me
started on this it's like no
Pennsylvania's just racist you don't
have to call it the South you [ __ ]
[ __ ] Mountain garbage garbage all
right I want you guys to vote based on
everything and those two stories and
then I'm gonna then I'm gonna add one
caveat and then we'll be done if you
want to be done it's your [ __ ]
podcast Jesus I'm telling you when your
podcasting is fine I think you can't you
know I think it's it's tough man I mean
this guy is [ __ ] in one breath he's
telling me he uses Tom's charcoal and an
expertise and he does dog tranquilizers
I don't know who to believe
[Laughter]
[ __ ] Tyler Durden over here yeah so
I'm I'm gonna say your know your your
trap you've grew up your bars you pure
trash I think you're trying to break
those break that break the chains from
the garbage a little bit but it's still
in you through and through regardless of
how successful you get la you know you
can't polish up a third you know what I
mean it's it's still in it's still in
your heart you still got a garbage heart
which I respect but you got to let you
got a couple of bucks now you can afford
some nicer things so that's the same
reformed semi reformed on the road to
reform I should say I'm gonna say this
okay this was one of the most
interesting conversations that we had on
this show
hands down like Kevin said you've got a
lot [ __ ] you know South Africa Boston
College everything you're doing along
that brother in the joint your law
degree yeah then you got that listen I'm
gonna tell you straight out your [ __ ]
garbage 100% is no way that ain't gonna
change I want to die I want to say
you're not but if there's too much right
here
why you're right I was the guy who
killed the guy the whole time at Nelson
Mandela's compound where we were staying
I stole a towel because it had dulciman
those initials on all the towel from
Nelson Mandela I do not like probably
got federal crimes man you're going to
hell okay okay I felt guilty because of
the reason cuz I'm like what the [ __ ] in
my head I was like these are in he had a
compound these are in every house it's
like still in a hotel towel and it's
guys initials on it and I want it you
know and I took it put it in my bag I
put it back quote unquote but like it's
just like we were leaving and I guilt
overcame me and then I just like took it
out of my bag and like dropped it behind
a book just like the most like just put
this here it's fine move you could do
I'm trash trash by you know what that
guy had to go through to get that
monogrammed towel yeah it wasn't easy
I'll tell you that some [ __ ]
hillbilly from his Tennessee comes and
Clips it nice enough to invite you in
his house in your [ __ ] lifts and [ __ ]
I was gonna say that you had to return
it as Nelson Mandela called you up and
Buster you know you would never call me
your garbage but I think you're on I
think you're I think you're gonna end
you'll die less garbage then you started
no we're on the scale that will be or
when it will be but you're you you've
pulled yourself from the bottom of the
dumpster to the top but if you ever get
invited to president Kanye West's
inauguration or anything like that
don't steal anything I'm definitely will
he's he's just he's got an album coming
out right that's what that's what I'm
that's a play can I ask y'all a question
of course do you remember when we met
we do I think I was thinking about that
I was driving back to New York this
morning
all right so I'm gonna I'm gonna be a
little what do we call it vulnerable
here or whatever sure when I met these
guys these guys were this may not be
true but in my mind y'all were in
control of a room I wanted to get booked
at and my friends introduced me to you
guys and you guys were busted my
friend's balls I forget who it was the
jet ski was there and I think cus
Carelli okay I think you were going
harder at customer ally and the reason I
think that is he's the easiest person to
go hard at in the whole world and they
weren't standing up for themselves and I
just moved in New York but I was an
older comic than those guys yeah so I
was like so I started [ __ ] on you
guys immediately and and I'm not gonna
lie like I was crushing it well however
you guys felt about it I was doing
pretty good I liked it right away but
like my thought process was like hey my
friends are standing up themselves and
be oh they're like too young in the
comedy world to know this is what we do
mm-hmm but you guys sold so hard like
you guys respond was like who the [ __ ]
is this [ __ ] in my solo said who
the [ __ ] the new guy I remember her
saying that you guys sold it so well and
I wouldn't I would never have told you
guys this until you asked me to be a
guest on your podcast like I remember
like for a few days like texting my
friends like I'm never getting [ __ ]
book there Emily like they hate me like
I offended the [ __ ] out of these guy
just movies me yet again
what's the trash thing it's the trash
thing like yet again I moved to a new
city I'm meeting new people and I just
[ __ ] ruin it walk in and insult
somebody while they're eating breakfast
in their own [ __ ] house that's a very
me move as well but I think if I had to
guess I Weaver's I responded that way
cuz it was like one I didn't even I
don't think I had said hi to you I feel
like I got jabbed in the face like I was
a boxer I was oh I don't know what's
going on
just like to your credit no no I sold it
your bit became who the [ __ ] do you
think you are you little [ __ ] or
whatever that was like what y'all were
and anyway I just was curious of y'all
remember I do remember yeah sure showed
up and tried to find everybody long
story short because they took it I can't
be around [ __ ] drew Morgan ladies and
gentlemen he's got a he's got a special
coming out very soon called Greatest
Hits you can find that on his website
you can just follow me on social media
drew more good comedy Instagram Twitter
wherever else
I drew Morgan on Facebook if you know
buddy demographic buddy that was
absolutely fainted we we appreciate it
kitty what do you got guys again thanks
so much for all the support getting us
into the charts and everybody sharing it
and all the feedback has been [ __ ]
awesome we appreciate it everybody that
I heard us on legion of skanks and then
came over to hang with us we really
appreciate it if you haven't already
please make sure you rate review
subscribe on iTunes and the full video
is available on YouTube you can
subscribe there as well and I am at
Kevin Ryan comedy on all social media
very nice yeah I want to reiterate that
shout out to all the skanks out there
everybody that supported us when we were
on the show we really really really
appreciate it we're so happy to be a
cast digital and we love you guys h-holy
on ice folder grams on instagram drew
Morgan this was an absolutely fantastic
episode thank you buddy and you'd be
safe out there okay thank you guys so
much this was so much fun